incredible breakthrough once again
there's so much news going on at the
moment in the property sector especially
in the UK so
hmos I said this would happen man I
talked about this years ago
hmos are not getting more regulated okay
service accommodations getting a little
bit more regulated but hmos are not in
fact hmos are getting less regulated
right now and I've been doing hmos full
time I got a lot of hmos uh for over 10
years in fact coming up to 15 now I
bought my first HMO in 2009 so what is a
HMO it's a house of multiple occupany
when you buy a house and rent it out
room by room now this is the thing okay
this is the naughty trick that the
councils and the government have been
doing to hurt my hmos and some of my
students so what they've been doing
previously is you buy a house let's say
you buy a house in Birmingham right
middle of England for £200,000
you buy that house house and you rent it
out room by room chaa right maybe you
got four five six rooms
whatever now when you do that you can
make a fortune doing this and this is
what I be because because the whole
house might rent out for a grand but
each room might rent out for
£500 and if you got six rooms that's
£3,000 a month rent coming in however
you have to pay the bills so if you're
paying the bills and the bills are a
grand
you still got two grand left so you're
making a lot of
profit now what the councils started
doing many many years ago now I was
getting burned by this in 2014 2015
Dudley
Council gez what they started doing was
they'd say gez if you've got HMO and
you're making a load of money we want
some of that money so they would start
saying because your house is being
rented out to five people and because
they've got um because each
room has got an on Suite maybe you put a
little kitchenet in there that's is kind
of its own dwelling it's like it's own
little it's like a it's like a studio
little apartment isn't it the council
would say no it's not a studio apartment
it's a HMO so they' say because it's
like a self-contained little
room we're going to change your council
tax baning so now instead of paying one
lot of council tax you're having to pay
council tax on every room
so that that that a killer like absolute
killer cuz now instead of let's say
instead of paying 300 a month for one
council tax on HMO you have to pay a
bunch of council taxes for each room you
might have to pay £1,000 a month council
tax so now your profit that was two
grand a month is now almost half now
it's like a
grand it might be worse than now your
profit was a grand and now it's only 300
quid right so it it's really hurting and
this is the interesting thing the
councils I swear that they were just
after me and my
students like The councils would do
this just randomly to just ahmo oh
Samuel lead zones that HMO boom you have
to pay council tax on each on each room
and I'm like okay well is that the case
with all hmos in this area and I'd study
it and I'd look and it was a bit gray
the law was a bit gray I felt like I was
being victimized at times and I also
think they were only doing it to to
landlords where they knew that that
particular
HMO was really profitable and they just
picked that one sometimes there was
other hmos in the same street that were
just paying one council tax Band but my
HMO I'm having to pay bang bang bang
like multiple council tax um to the
council so I'm getting hit so that you
know so it it was quite unfair and this
is something something that I talked
about um very loudly to my students a
couple of years ago and we campaigned
and we wrote to the councilors and we
pushed and we've been pushing for a long
time and I'm over the moon to see that
now this is looking like our voices as
HMO landlords have been heard and and
and and I've just literally this is new
information from literally like a couple
weeks ago um gov.uk website council tax
valuation on houses in multiple
occupation consultation okay so this is
in consultation so this isn't law now
but the consultation is going to end on
the 21st of December so it's being
debated right now but what's being put
forward is incredible what's being put
forward is that the new law will be and
I I assume this will get
in um but we'll see the new law will be
that hmos are
banded as just one council tax um to pay
which is going to be huge but the thing
that's excited me more than anything is
the way that the government are talking
about hmos I'm going to leave a link to
this and I want I want you to read this
consultation um because the way they're
talking about
hmos is just it's almost like they've
been listening to my YouTube videos I
mean look at
this
hmos form an an important important part
of the housing market that's nice to
hear the government saying often
providing cheaper accommodation for
people whose housing options are limited
it is estimated that there are 500,000
hmos in England the nature of hmos has
continue to evolve over time with
improvements in quality and variation in
size and types of properties hmos can
provide affordable housing options for
some of the most vulnerable and
disadvantaged groups such as those on
low incomes hmos are also contributing
to the Regeneration of our high streets
with high quality hmos being used to
provide affordable accommodation for
young professionals and this just goes
on and on and on
hmos as with all domestic property are
given council tax Bann by the valuation
office agency so the vaa they're the
people that decide how much council tax
you have to pay and they're the people
that going to be forced to only be able
to ban you as one count um you pay C tax
once on the whole house um
um so so I'm not going to read the whole
thing with changes in the quality of
offering some hmos there is a risk that
legislation has not kept up with the
improvements in the quality of HMO
accommodation and how such properties
should be treated for council tax as a
result some HMO properties are being
assessed in such a way as to attract a
counil tax Band for each individual unit
this may here's the bit this may
discourage HMO landlords from making
improvements to their properties as well
as acting as a deterrent to new
landlords entering the HMO Market okay
what does that mean oh I mean for a
start they're bang on right they're
talking about how basically what they're
saying is because I've done this I've
even taught my students I've said to
them look be careful putting on Suites
in certain um properties like I know if
you've got hmos in Dudley that the
Dudley Council came after me and some of
my students and and and and it was a
nightmare so now I'm saying if I if I if
I'm teaching somebody and they're living
in Dougley I'm going to say look get a
HMO but maybe avoid putting on sweets in
the rooms cuz they're going to come for
you uh if I'm speaking to someone in
ketering I might say yeah get HMO there
and put on sweets there but don't put
any um kitchenet in the rooms because
then it will be deemed as a separate by
that particular Council for example so
what's what the government have finally
realized is that what that's doing is
it's making people that own hmos not
want to put not want to improve the
property not want to put on sweets and
kitchenet and just make it nice and cuz
then then the council will see they're
making a lot of money it might be seen
more as a separate unit as a separate
entity as a room and then they'll come
for you and the and the government are
saying that's not good we should be
encouraging and then this this bit as
well um uh this may discourage HMO
landlords from making improvements of
their properties as well as acting as a
deterrent to new landlords entering into
the HMO Market what does that mean that
means that the government
want HMO landlords to to get into the
market and to get into the HMO business
which is which is so beautiful to hear
because if the government can appreciate
what we're doing and I've been said like
you know we've got a massive housing
crisis going on there's not enough
houses so to buy a house and to rent it
out room by room you're providing
affordable housing for people and also
there's a lot of homeless people in the
UK at the moment homelessness is going
up so if you're providing more
properties more affordable accommodation
£500 for a room including
bills I mean yeah I'm making a lot of
money off the back of it of course
that's business it's a free market but
at the same time I'm making money cuz
I'm providing a service which is
£500 and you've got your bills included
you got your furniture your fast Wi-Fi I
mean you'd be hard pressed to pay £500
for an apartment and then you got all
your bills you got your removal costs so
it's making it affordable people to live
and the government are waking up to this
and they're making it easier um yeah so
as I said I'm not going to read the
whole thing but it's incredible and
what's happening is good so I want to
thank the government for listening to us
um I'm going to put a link to this also
another thing that's is
amazing if you've not thought about
doing this you should do it which is
renting a
house and turning into a
HMR under a rent to rent contract this
is huge um you can you can do this in
pretty much any area in the UK as long
as you're aware of the rules and the
legislations um uh so many of my
students have not got the money to begin
with 100 Grand to buy a house and what
but what they're do is they work working
alongside student uh uh landlords and
they're taking on their properties and
then they're running the property and
making all the profit from the HMO side
but then the landlord or the owner is
getting the rent so this is called rent
to rent rent to HMO I'm going to be
Runing a whole day training on this as
well as talking about the laws um
different areas Article 4 if you want to
come and spend the day with me I'm going
to leave a link below in the description
uh find the rent to rent crash course
okay um that's going to be running this
month and I'll see you guys we soon